write an inequality that fits the graph
shown below so here they've graphed a
line in red and the inequality includes
this line because it's in bold red it's
not a dashed line it's going to be all
of the area above it so it's all the
area y is going to be greater than or
equal to this line so first we just have
to figure out the equation of this line
we can figure out its y intercept just
by looking at it its y intercept is
right there let me do that in a darker
color
its y intercept is right there at y is
equal to negative 2 that's the point 0
negative 2. so if you think about this
line if you think about its equation as
being of the form y is equal to mx
plus b in slope intercept form we
figured out b is equal to negative two
so that is negative two right there and
let's think about its slope let's think
about its slope
if we move
if we move two in the x direction
if we if delta x is equal to 2 if our
change in x is positive 2 what is our
change in y our change in y
our change in y is equal to negative 1.
slope
or this m
is equal to change in y
over change in x
which is equal to in this case
negative one over two or negative one
half and just to reinforce and you could
have done this anywhere you could have
said hey what happens if i go back four
in x
so if i went back fourth delta x was
negative four
if delta x is equal to negative four
then delta y
is equal to positive two delta y would
be equal to positive two and once again
delta y over delta x
would be positive two would be positive
two over negative four
which is also negative one half i just
want to reinforce that it's not
dependent on how far i move along in x
or whether i go forward or backward
you're always going to get or you should
always get the same slope it's negative
one-half so the equation of that line is
y is equal to the slope negative
one-half
x
plus the y-intercept minus two that's
the equation of this line
right there now this inequality is
includes that line and everything above
it for any x value let's say x is equal
to 1. this line will tell us well if you
take well let's take this point so we
get to an integer let's say that x is
equal to 2.
let me get rid of that one let's say x
is equal to 2. when x is equal to 2 this
value is going to give us negative
one-half times two which is negative one
minus two is going to give us negative
three
negative three but this inequality isn't
just y is equal to negative three y
would be negative three or all of the
values greater than negative three and i
know that because they shaded in this
whole area up here so the equation or i
should say the inequality that fits the
graph here below is and i'll do it in
i'll do it in a in a bold color is y
is greater than or equal to negative one
half x
minus two that is the
inequality that is depicted in this
graph where this is just the line but we
want all of the area above and equal to
the line so that's what we have for the
inequality